[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
je vous dis med
[Applaudissements]
il ya une grosse crime sur le plateau je
les sens qui commence à megève et
bienvenue à tous pas mort elles sont
voilées ou aller où elle est où elle est
où la moue la gamme l'amour la grosse
paul da mota
elle est rouée néo la volaille
[Applaudissements]
obama
mes frais
maxime est là ouais mais bon nous on est
là et ça va bien et là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis dit qu'après vous un jour
enfermé j'ai tombé
je suis tombé
[Applaudissements]
l'offre combien pense que les deux
sources
croustillant donne encore plus envie de
faire
[Applaudissements]
c'était
[Musique]
sert à rien mais c'est indispensable
bah c'est un petit peu comme vous dans
l'émission
finalement si je dis aux in swing bad
gones valadier va te faire [ __ ]
[Rires]
tu as garé
mais je ne suis qu'un faux coup
tu cherches il manque une fichiers
[Musique]
et moi je vais vous dire un truc je vous
lis pas si vous faites non je suis de
plus en plus longs mais j'adore le mètre
carré
mais écoutez moi bien à la patte du pp
je suis dans le flou certain que le
paquet
[Musique]
à quoi vous vous ré voulait faire toi
comme métier moi je suis toujours voulu
être acteur
non pas du tout je vous êtes chanteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais
un prof
moi dans une bibliothèque j'ai vraiment
une très grosse prochain jumeaux oui
mais je m'en bats les couilles
on est très très agitée aujourd'hui
[Musique]
jennifer pan elle porte un tee shirt de
chedjou c'est une petite marque qui paye
pas de mine
c'est magnifique regardez alors ça
représente deux personnes qui s'aiment
au bord de l'océan
là je reconnais c'est l'article portait
un magnifique jeans à cet incident payet
j'aime beaucoup et là bien entendu
et bien voilà on est là j'ai besoin
kenya les matières nobles ils sont là
voilà mesdames ce christ piscine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une idée
[Rires]
[Musique]
les embrasse moi bah c'est bon ouais bah
ça vaut bien voilà
allez
[Applaudissements]
je pense que je peux décider mais t'es
mort
[Applaudissements]
braguette ouverte c'est arrivé à fabien
lecoeuvre un jour il ya eu d'évacuation
des locaux les gens dont on a retrouvé
le monstre du loch ness
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
m
[Musique]